this video is sponsored by Nord PPN
protect yourself online today by
visiting Nord VPN comm forward slash
totally not mark for a special offer in
the summer of 2015 after an 18 year long
hiatus Dragonball returned to television
running for 131 episodes finishing in
the spring of 2018 later that same year
Dragon Ball super bro Lee became the
highest-grossing Dragon Ball film in
history during that same time period
Dragon Ball became as popular as ever
entertaining old fans and attracting new
ones so a few weeks back I decided to
ask on my Twitter if given the choice
between Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball
super which series did you prefer with
over 2,000 votes cast these were the
results with the overwhelming majority
voted for Dragon Ball Z / Dragon Ball
super 77 percent to just 23 and these
were some of the most popular reasons
folks gave for choosing Dragon Ball Z
they felt the characters were more
tightly written in z ox didn't feel
disconnected or isolated like in Super
and the art styles it was presented in
seem to be more favorable however
regardless of these reasons 77% of the
folks on Twitter still considered Dragon
Ball Z a cut above Dragon Ball super so
before we begin this video let's see
what you guys on YouTube think which is
better cast your vote in the top right
it's obvious that Dragon Ball super was
missing something as sparked that Dragon
Ball Z seem to possess and so today I
want to take a look from a writer's
perspective at what Dragon Ball super
did write what it did very wrong and why
I think Dragon Ball super Broly could
mean great things for the series of once
it returns later this year let's dive in
[Music]
what worked and what didn't
to understand what didn't work in Dragon
Ball super we must first understand what
worked in Dragon Ball Z and most
importantly why it worked and
unsurprisingly with a show like Dragon
Ball Z to find what worked and what
didn't work is a rather simple
Enterprise firstly the moments that have
worked on the show have become some of
the most standout nostalgia trips for
the entire series for these moments I am
of course talking about seems like
piccolo protecting Gohan the Goku
turning Super Saiyan transformation for
the first time the Vegeta sacrificing
himself to save his family and friends
etc etc however something that's
observed when looking at most of the
large successful moments throughout
Dragon Ball is that many of them while
grand and spectacular are successful
because there's an emotional component
at its core with history when he was
first introduced piccolo jr. was after
world domination but at the climax of
his arc gave up his life for his sworn
enemies son it wasn't just the fact that
this was a nice thing piccolo did for
Gohan that made it as emotionally
resonant as it was instead it was the
contrast of where he had been at one
point in his life many years ago it's
for this very reason that the ending to
the tournament of power worked in some
respects the combination of Goku and
Frieza fighting side-by-side was
something no one could have ever seen
coming given their history and it's that
contrast that made it so exciting to
watch it was their journey and it's that
long-form storytelling that was sorely
lacking in Dragon Ball super I made a
video in January called son Goku the
misunderstood character in which I spoke
about how Goku's character is at its
best when it creates change in the world
and characters around them if we look at
piccolo Gohan and Vegeta as examples of
what character development can do for a
series like Dragon Ball Z imagine if we
were to replace their arcs with the arcs
found in super stagnant not undergoing
any sort of development or change that
affects the long term just plotting
along doing their thing I can assure you
as a result in Z those moments wouldn't
have worked
go on piccolo and Vegeta all had to
overcome themselves and their lies they
believed and so if we strip the
characters of these elements then they
become significantly less interesting
and the show suffers as a consequence
work as a flat character alongside them
as a result and the entire show loses
these great moments we love to discuss
character development what's worth
mentioning at this juncture is that
super was not devoid of developing
characters and as I mentioned before
it's in these moments Goku does some of
his best work as a character characters
like hid who developed a respect and
appreciation for Goku's philosophy zu ma
su who because of his warped
understanding of the world around him
and Goku's actions changed for the worse
and finally Jared who despite being very
cliche did undergo a considerable
positive change towards the end of the
series so super is most definitely not
lacking in characters who develop but
what it is lacking in and this is where
it differs from Dragon Ball Z quite
considerably is how long these
characters are part of the story for and
whether or not they influence the story
in any meaningful capacity thereafter
but before we get into the best part of
this video and how Broly fits into all
this towards the end of last year as
many of you I'm sure are aware article
13 threatened the livelihoods of
thousands of European creators as well
as the online freedoms of millions with
net neutrality acts rearing their heads
in the United States relentlessly
article 13 now in Europe and whatever
I'm sure is to come I am proud to
announce that Nord VPN had decided to
sponsor this video I don't normally
accept sponsors but believe me what I
say this one is worth it if you want to
protect your personal data or search
history have peace of mind with or
without article 13 or maybe you just
want to surf the web from another
country Nord VPN is not only the answer
but is ridiculously easy to use and if
you follow the link in the description
Nord VPN comm forward slash totally not
Marc you'll find it's incredibly cheap -
currently the offer is 75% off for three
years that's military grade internet
security for the price of a cup of
coffee $2.99 per month and if you use
coupon code holy nut mark you get an
extra month absolutely free again if
you'd like to protect yourself against
article 13 our net neutrality or perhaps
want to support this channel please
check out the link Nord VPN comm four
slash totally nut mark in the
description to see it for yourself
it's a terrific service now back to the
video one of the most cutting and
accurate criticisms made against Dragon
Ball super in retrospective was how
disconnected and isolated it's Eric's
felt from one another in super there was
a visible effort made to connect the
battle of God's arc
to the resurrection F ark but outside of
that none of the other acts tied
together at all
instead the series treats every
individual ark after resurrection F as
almost its own standalone story
typically with little or no consequences
lasting after the closing episode of
that given Ark there seems to be an
intense desire for those working at
to--we or perhaps accurate Orianna to
write something with the conclusion
wrapped up in a bow when in reality what
made Dragon Ball Z feel like a grand
space opera was the very opposite it
implemented the following ark structure
in the beginning there is the ending of
an old life the taking up of a new one
and it all ends with a question this can
be observed over most arcs in the
original run of Dragonball when we pick
up with Goku at the beginning of Dragon
Ball Z he is living a modest life with
his son Gohan and his wife chichi
but that life as he knows it ends when
Raddatz arrives and reveals that he is
an alien from the planet Vegeta before
stealing his son away this triggers his
new life where he must defeat Raddatz
and travel to King Kai's planet to
prepare for Vegeta and nappa the ark
concludes with a savage confrontation
but also with the question how will they
revive their fallen friends and will
vegeta travel to Namak to find the
Dragon Balls to jurymen AMEX saga Goku's
life as an earth fighter ends as he
begins his new life as a rebel to the
forces of Frieza during which his life
as he knew it ended beginning in you as
the first super saiyan in over a
thousand years ending on the question if
Goku survived Namek why isn't he coming
home how did he survive similar to the
Saiyan sagas final question asked of the
audience bleeding over into the Namek
sagas beginning so too does the nameks
ending bleed into the Android cell arc
where Goku learns that time travel
exists the human race is going to be
destroyed and he will die to the heart
virus this marks the end of Goku's
current way of life and marks the
beginning of a new one where he will
take the measures necessary to preserve
the earth a new view that allows it to
see that his son is the future
eventually arriving at the very end of
the arc with the question will we ever
see Goku again not only does this method
breed intrigue around the community
watching thus ensuring a larger turnout
for the coming arc but it also creates a
larger sense of continuity a sense that
this story is going somewhere as opposed
to it being its own standalone piece
finished a complete arc after arc much
like super has done and the interesting
thing about this philosophy of story
rising when put next to Dragon Ball
super is that while not used in the arcs
super does implement this structure in
almost every episode and one that
demonstrates this better than any other
is episode 47 in this episode trunks his
life as he knows it ends with the death
of his mother Bulma this also marks the
beginning of his new life as an orphan
fighting to escape to the Past alone
ending with the question will Trump's
escape and for the audience who is that
the problem I see with super Zack
structure is that all of them seem to be
isolated with no effort put into tying
them together to create a sense that
this is all one grand story rather than
5 segmented ones resurrection F ends
with freezes death there are really no
consequences carried over into the
universe 6 tournament arc as a result
everything seems very separate the last
episode of that universe 6 tournament
AXYZ beerus make a selfless wish on his
brothers behalf representing an easing
of tensions between the two which was
established at the beginning of the
earth everything ends neatly and has no
carryover to the beginning of the Future
Trunks arc there is no cliffhanger
question that is asked of the audience
and there is no overarching development
of a particular character to tie it all
together the form Super Saiyan blue did
not work for this very reason it didn't
seem special because there was no
established story behind its conquest
Goku simply shows up and has it in the
movie while in the show in a very short
period of time they achieve it the Super
Saiyan form was something told over a
much longer time span in Z and upon its
unveiling made a huge moment in anime
history and this is precisely why the
form ultra instinct landed and worked
much better than Super Saiyan blue as it
was hinted at from the beginning of
Dragon Ball super between goku and
beerus fighting on King Kai's planet as
well as weas lecturing them while
training at various instances ultra
instinct seems like it was destined to
happen since the beginning preordained
and because of that when it shows up it
works super introduced loads of new
characters
beerus Wiese pyjamas sorbet hidden zaman
sugu gerund um
many others in the tournament of power
and the series throughout however most
of them didn't develop at all and the
few that did did so while restricted to
one specific arc now in the case of
characters like Kaaba who did
technically develop over the course of
the show and it does help characters
like Vegeta become more compelling he is
on his own a very minor character that
offers little to the story beyond being
a pupil to Vegeta unlike Gohan piccolo
and Vegeta who during Dragon Ball Z
impacted and guided the plot at a
regular intervals by being active
characters within the story Kaaba is a
reactive character the story happens to
him but recently there has been a
character that's been introduced one
that is interesting has so much more to
tell and one that we have yet to see
develop fully and that character is
[Applause]
[Music]
the Canon introduction of Brawley to a
series like Dragonball could not have
come at a better time despite being a
relic of a more nostalgic era the
worldwide positive reception for not
only this film but also the Broly
character has been nothing short of
overwhelming initially painted in Dragon
Ball Z as an angry one-dimensional
muscle monster with Akira Toriyama sped
he has become a sympathetic complicated
for nuanced character full of endearing
qualities to go along with a tragic
backstory
however bro Lee brings much more than
simple tragedy he brings what I believe
to be promised towards the end of the
film after having been defeated Frieza
remarks that he needs an ally if he is
to win against Goku and Vegeta in the
future it's heavily implied that this
ally he has in mind will be brawling in
that same breath the movie ends with the
scene between Goku beginning to build a
relationship with Broly these were
important moments to me because it
indicates future plans for a power
struggle to gain broglie's trust over
the comic arcs this is not only
interesting and fits perfectly well
within bro Lee's character who
rightfully should have a host of trust
issues at this point but most
importantly teases something the initial
run of Dragon Ball super was sorely
lacking something that will enrich
Goku's archetype and the flow of the
show a new main character that will
develop over the course of the series
alongside the main cast Dragon Ball
super bro Lee has provided the impending
super animes return with a chance for
long-term multi arc spanning character
development packed with personality and
intrigue a crucial element for any
long-running show one that's absence
caused the initial run of Dragon Ball
super to feel needlessly disjointed and
disconnected something was missing and
oddly enough the character that once
represented everything I disliked about
Dragon Ball might now represent
everything I think Dragon Ball needs
quick or non-existent character arcs
disconnected sagas and boring revisions
of classic moments are the biggest sins
of the initial run of super I believe
and with everything said and done the
missing principal the missing practice
and the missing ingredient might be
rediscovered through growing thanks for
watching
you
[Music]